i have with me suleiman of ftth council
mina siliman nice to talk to you today
here in warsaw now you guys of all the
ftth countries in the world you have the
crown jewels in uae don't you
yes we sure do uh it's really fortunate
although our region is is
relatively small we have very
interesting talk about
the uae uae has been ranked number one
for the past three years and ftth
penetration so they have uh covered most
of the country with ftth installations
that's amazing just tell us actually
across
mina as you define it what countries are
you responsible for
actually we are responsible from the
east uh iran from in the east all the
way to morocco on the west so we covered
the 11 countries which is the middle
eastern countries plus north african
countries
yes so you've got quite a quite a
challenging market there how is the
market looking at the moment for ftta
well uh the market it's it's segmented
basically you know we have uh two groups
or let's say three groups of countries
we have a very dynamic market in the gcc
countries which is which are the the
gulf states namely uae saudi arabia
qatar
and we also have oman and kuwait are
coming very strong although they don't
have a lot of ftth installation as of
yet however they have government
announcements that they will definitely
work on this in the next few years
and the other side
on the other side we have countries with
that are politically unstable
you know such as iraq syria libya yemen
palestine
these countries they have potential
however because of the political
situation
they have no fiber at this point
and then you have countries in the
middle
you know you we hear government
announcement to roll out you know mbn
networks and that is happening in jordan
that's happening in morocco and tunisia
so
these countries we we expect you know to
you know the fcth rollout will increase
eventually in the next few years
however the most dynamic countries are
basically the gcc countries okay so yeah
so i guess i mean what are the big sort
of challenges and opportunities you know
where do you feel sort of the uh the
next big step is going to come i think
the next step is is if governments
are are to step in actually to to help
in the process and we feel this is
important if we leave it just to the
operators you know to deploy fiber it's
not going to happen you know in a short
period of time so i think government
should step in and they should focus on
the national broadband network
eventually based on ultra-fast fiber
connectivity do you think the
governments are becoming aware of the
need to do this i think so little by
little
but surely i think they are
for example jordan now is is building a
new
mbn network
kuwait have just announced two big
g-pawn projects
also morocco are working on their uh nbn
as well
so we feel that these countries will
have very good potential for ftt age
conductivity
well good luck with it thank you very
much for talking to us you're most
welcome thank you so the mena region has
the crown jewels has some challenges but
also some major developments being
announced for ftth